in today's morning rounds we are looking
at new research on when to screen your
children for autism autism is a spectrum
disorder that may affect social skills
behavior and communication and a study
in the medical journal JAMA Pediatrics
suggests children could be diagnosed as
early as 14 months current guidelines
recommend screenings during regular
doctor visits at 18 to 24 months when
the earlier diagnosis could also mean
earlier treatment mara dr. David agus
joins us from Los Angeles doctor good to
see you
we now know that one and fifty-nine
children have been diagnosed with autism
how helpful can an early diagnosis be
it's paramount what we know is is that
classically here in the United States
autism is diagnosed around age three and
age for even though we screen for it
slightly earlier and the brain is
developing earlier so if you could
diagnose it at age 14 months before the
connections have been made is called
plasticity those connections through
behavioral therapy can be stronger and
so the hope is we can influence the
brain with behavioral therapy much
earlier before those connections really
start to kick in so we can actually have
late better function later in life in
these children with autism spectrum
disorder so David what is it that gets
how are they able to detect it earlier
so we have thought that if you start to
see late change or delay behavior in
children at an early age
well we gotta watch till age two and
three to know if it's autism spectrum
disorder in this study by age fourteen
months by doing standardized testing
they could actually with eighty four
percent accuracy diagnosed autism 14
percent of the kids who were diagnosed
as potentially having ASD autism
spectrum disorder actually had another
development of the disorder only two
percent of the kids who they thought had
ASD actually developed normally through
a later years so this is a very
important study and has a lot of
optimism for bringing earlier treatment
to kids what is the latest data say
about what causes autism I wish we
really knew but what we know is there's
a significant genetic association with
it
and what we also know is that the older
the parent is the higher the likelihood
of a child having autism spectrum
disorder we think it's involved in brain
development in the first and second
trimester but that's about it
what we do know definitively is that
vaccines do not cause autism can I ask
you about this different study that was
out earlier this year excuse me this
month that found that autism systems
symptoms dropped by 45% after a fecal
transplant tell us about that that is
amazing I mean what they showed is that
most children with autism or adults with
autism have either constipation or
diarrhea and in this study they gave
antibiotics followed by seven or eight
weeks of a pill that contains somebody
else's bacteria and they showed a 45
percent reduction in the autism symptoms
but it lasted for up to two years which
is how long they followed in a study so
this brings tremendous optimism you get
rid of other biologic issues going on
like the GI things and the brain can
function better so it didn't get rid of
the autism disorder but at the same time
it dramatically improves symptoms and
allow the children or the adults to
function better more to be done on the
microbiome David thank you so much